j'ai pas demandé à elsa et sportives
alors là comme ça oui comme ça n'en fait
pas tout de suite vous des mots tu as
deux heures d'émission avec mettez-vous
partir avec une invite en jeu ne croule
pas sous les propositions
j'aimerais bien partir avec nikos qui
n'est visité les cyclades corps bien
partir avec des gens qu'ils avouent y
vont et puis avec qui vous ne partiriez
absolument pas vouloir avec gilles
verdez ben voilà avec il vous partez en
vacances
bah moi j'avais dit nikos aussi aux non
mais oh la belle mais j'ai honte d'être
de toros avec elsa parce qu'elle est
beaucoup trop mignonne à me suis tordu
je suis ni cause si vous acceptez les
deux je pense qu'en ce moment par
ensemble soit sinon je change
je me permets une petite infidélité et
je prends laurent delahousse à l'euro de
la sib est de coutume donne des idées
excellent choix et je ne portais pas
avec je crois que je pars pas avec
patrick sébastien
alors avec qu'ils partiront
rassemblement alors sur mon moteur de
recherche génie animateur télé qui aime
jouer au poker aime jouer au tennis et
en même temps qui me laisse du temps
pour pouvoir lire j'ai trouvé cyril
hanouna tombé par hasard alors vous vous
avez vraiment envie de bayonne après
onze remanié de la chaîne mais vous dire
ou pas et cela s'est autodissous oui
peut-être combien 15,3 à pas mal et vous
ne partez pas vu qui avec amiens
pourquoi parce qu'en fait il est trop
kazan il m'a dit qu'ils détestent et
partir ils aiment rester chez lui il
déteste les avions il déteste faire ses
valises
salon goisses haut et moi j'adore partir
donc je pense qu'on voit là je pourrai
pas être compatible avec annie pour ces
vacances là avec une part en vacances
avec jean pierre foucault
ah oui webb a cédé sacrée soirée avec
lui surtout il a plongé dans les années
dans la piscine de d'intervilles parce
que il a surfé sur cette activité
pendant tout l'été quand j'étais gosse
et surtout je crois qu'il vit dans les
alentours de marseille hilary ware car
ils vous voitures de collection en
décapotable 4l et une petite promenade
un petit cours d'année
c'est du grand n'importe quoi qu'est ce
que vous avez fait ce que je croyais que
jean pierre foucault envie de partir
mais dans ce cas nul
il annule tous humains gerbi et avec qui
vous ne voulez pas parti avec georges
pernoud ce bon vieux loup de mer parce
que j'ai levé le verre regardez je
pensais à la photo que j'ai préparé moi
je pars avec vous à mon passé grand
chose avec el fayot non mais bastien
d'abord pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
parce que vous êtes très sympathique et
c'est vrai vous êtes assez drôle je suis
en train de le promouvoir mon nouveau
spectacle qui démarre à paris avant 7
heures un spectacle assez drôle rappelle
rappelle que j'étais l'un des premiers à
venir vous voir des vrais voilà et puis
et puis j'ai vu votre femme
oui quand même très très bas c'est drôle
aussi voilà donc et puis surtout c'est
aussi j'ai si je veux faire un barbecue
d'accord ok donc vous venez bloc face à
bab occupants dont vous faites ma faim
pour moi c'est dit franchement ici at il
dit les choses
ah ouais c'est le meilleur je trouve
sympa gentil les droits humains généreux
j'adore c'est pas le concours du
meilleur animateur ce avec qui on a
envie de partir on va là pour être aimé
quand il part passe avec arthur ne
partage rien nous n'avons pas les mêmes
valeurs vous avez d'abord il vous fera
découvrir pas mal de choses
arthur alors avec qui je partirai comme
animateur et ben justement j'y avais pas
pensé mais camille parce qu'on se
rapproche un peu il est très casanier
moi aussi je suis très casanière et
sinon changement de génération tirer
ardisson que sa carrière me fascine et
j'aimerais trop tu me racontes pendant
les heures de passage lui faire
plusieurs partir en vacances et d'avoir
quelques côtés sur le matelas qui lui
pose des questions sur sa carrière
seulement sur sa carrière mais le
personnage martigues